and so hello everybody my name is Adrian
trout I'm a front-end engineer at da da
da our topic today is how to build
advanced search experiences with a
custom query language first I will focus
on the use case I will explain what a
custom query language is and are in the
benefits of introducing one in the
search interface then we'll see how to
implement it
in the code of your advanced search and
finally we'll cover differentiation to
onboard your users make sure to know we
have to get studying and authorize our
own queries so let's get a bit more into
the use case and what why is an advanced
search some time necessary in Okinawa
custom query language improves the user
experience I'm spending most of my day
working on our lab management tool at
dialogue and doing work management is
about allowing the user to search
through millions of events and finding
the right one and so this gives us a few
requirements for our search first since
it's about troubleshooting you're
running a lot of different searches
before you find the right information
for you so your search needs to be
really efficient because you're learning
a lot of things and you're using in the
tool a very long time also because you
need to find the right logs that will
explain to you what's happening inside
your infrastructure you search as also
to be very precise because otherwise you
will never find your needle in the
haystack and finally since logs can be
anything from system logs to database
events to front-end logs the format is
not there is like the data structure is
not known and so you have to make your
search flexible enough to be able to
search through all those kind of
different areas and so those our
requirements for the search they're not
really specific to log management but so
when we'll be working with today and
let's see how common search interfaces
match those requirements so that's the
basic keyword search you find on a roll
of website it's very nice because it's
simple you can just get started in a few
seconds so it's it's very efficient you
type a few keywords and in a few seconds
you already have
your first results but the limitation
with that keyword search search is
precision because phrasing well here if
I'm on a furniture store and looking for
a blue chair I have no way to tell the
system's that I'm not looking for these
are some things that's blue or a chair
and I'm looking for chairs that
specifically blue so you have no way to
give the system what your intent is and
to give the system more context about
what you're searching for so the way a
lot of website solves this is that they
sorry they introduce an advanced search
button and when you click on that better
and use you will see a lot of different
inputs and sliders and everything and
what this gives to you is a lot more
precision because every input as is on
intent so if I select the color blue all
my results are going to be blue this
time what you lose here with that
pattern is efficiency because you went
from a search where you could type a few
words and get results to a search where
you have to click around a lot and find
out which inputs are relevant to you and
also it makes it a lot less readable
because you have to look if you want to
know exactly what you're searching for
you have to look at every input and the
value of every input and finally it's
not that flexible because the way you
set up your inputs will define the way
users can search for something so for
example here I put one price range and
if the user want to search across two
price ranges he cannot do that so but as
a developer I actually know another way
another pattern to search for results
and that's where language is so that's
when you send for example to a database
or to an API some texts that's going to
return your results it's a first way
language that you usually learn about
when you when you start I don't know
when your child is natural language
that's asking a question in English it's
very flexible because you can ask any
question in English and it always will
make sense that's your own language
the issue with natural language is that
it's not made for computers so computers
that struggle with nuances and also the
range of question we you will be able to
ask is a lot bigger that's a question
you can answer on your website and so if
you have Google or Facebook money it may
be fine you may be able to solve that
problem but for your own tool on website
it's probably a bit overkill the second
query language that I encountered was
sequel and so that's a Korean language
for databases it's very powerful because
it allows you to query any kind of
structured data and also it has great
support so you have a lot of databases
supporting it and if you want to
implement it you basically send to
search through your servers directly to
the database you have nothing more to do
but this is for us it's not really good
for our use case because you have to
know how the data is stored to be able
to query it and that's not something we
want our users to care about and it's
it's a bit too complex and it's it's not
really what we want there and so one of
the systems that tries to solve this is
graph QL since it's an abstraction over
data storage it's a bit better because
you don't have to care about how the
data is stored and what's really nice
also is that you can define easily what
kind of output you want for your data
but it's still very much targeted to
api's so for example if you see that
query here and you would it's very nice
if you want to send it over HTTP or if
you're right here in your code but if
you want a user to write that query it's
a bit long it's a bit verbose so that's
not really what we want here so since
we've not been able to found any query
language that match our requirements
another solution since I'm a developer
is to make my own query language I found
a few example of companies that actually
did that so on jiriz there is actually
what they call gql which allows you to
search for your tasks through your
issues primitives that some original
monitoring tools they also have their
own way to create data and
adela look what I found really funny is
that there is another team that makes
unclear language to create data
visualizations and so we had two
different in finding the same way to
solve similar problems so what are the
benefit of benefits are having your own
custom query language first is it's as I
level as you want so you you are able to
decide what you want your users to care
about or not so for example if you want
your user to be able to define the
object format like in graph QL you can
include that in your language but if you
don't if you want to make it a bit more
simple you just remove that and and do
your own thing it's also very specific
to your use case so you can make sure
every word that the user types is
relevant to your domain and to express
what the user is looking for and there
is not anything technical getting in the
way and finally since it's really a high
level and use case specific it's also
very readable because the only words
that are in the query about your domain
and not technical so this seems to be a
good solution for our use case here so
to be and it's probably not perfect but
we'll get into the limitations a bit
later note that I know is that I want to
make my own query language I have to
define it and so a language definition
is called a grammar and so that's gonna
be the set of rules that define what a
valid search is and the meaning of each
word in my valid search two things you
should care about when writing your
grammar is that you have to make it
flexible enough for the user to be able
to write any kind of different queries
and also you want to make sure your most
important concepts the first thing the
user is going to look for is the things
that they the first things they have to
write so that they can benefit from your
parry language real fast let's give you
a quick example to give you a better
idea of whether grammar is so that's my
simplified English grammar obviously
we're not going to get into all the
rules of English now
but if I were to define a grammar for
English my first rule would be a
sentence is a set of words separated by
spaces and if I use that sorry if I use
that rule
I'm gonna be able to say well I have
three words in this sentence I like and
meatballs and then I can use a second
hole which would say the first one is
the subject second or is a verb and the
third is the object to say that o is my
subject like is my verb admit balls is
my object and so by defining all those
kind of rules we be able to extract
words and then the context of those
words and find the meaning of the
sentence
and note that we and we can apply that
to my example which is still a furniture
store and so if I were to write a
grammar for my furniture store search
language I would I would be able to
define a set of rules that say for
example a search query for my phone into
Stroh would be a list of furnitures
separated by spaces so here I have two
furnitures and inside each furnitures
there is first the type of the furniture
then brackets and inside the brackets as
there is a list of attributes I care
about for those furniture so by using
that rule I can say hey I'm looking for
a chair and a couch and the chair as the
attributes blue $100 and the couch has a
attribute green and if I want to go even
further I can say well actually in my
attributes every attribute that starts
with a hashtag will be a color and every
attributes that ends with the currency
will be a price so that's how you get
into writing your own query Rama and
once you've defined all those rules you
can once you define your grammar is the
next step is actually to implement it in
the code of your search and so that's
making the computer understand the
search queries so the goal here is to
get from a string to an object that will
be easier to enter in my code and will
be contained all the context that was
extracted from the string and then once
I have
an object that's very simple I can use
it anywhere in my if I want to create
databases if I want to extract
information from for the user or
anything like that once you have an
object you've pretty much done or all
the job so to go from from the string to
the object is actually called passing
and so passing will say well actually
from that query I extract that one word
is chair and since I have some grammar
rules I'm gonna be able to say well
actually chair is not a color because
it's the first word and it's not inside
brackets actually chair is the furniture
type so that's what passing is and so
the first thing I think about when I
want to extract informations from a
string is to try it with a regular
expression regular expression are really
efficient when you extracting
information from emails or Teflon so
when you know the number of things you
want to extract from your query it's
very good but when you don't know the
number of things your expression gets
really complex and also it's hard to
extract the context of the element to
extract it so if you it's easy to
extract for example chair but if I want
to absorb also that share will be a
funny to type that's gonna be a bit more
complex doing with a regex
and iPhones is really I think it's very
good code on Stack Overflow that says if
you write a regular expression you go
get a cup of coffee then you come back
and you have no idea what you just wrote
maybe a regular expression is not the
tool for you so I think that it's been
really why why this is not good for use
case here so the other solution to
extract information from a string is to
generate su pastor from my language
finish and from the grammar I just
explained in English I can actually
generate generate a pastor from that and
the way to do that is to write the
grammar in another grandma so there is
actually a way to read by mouth and
there are actually a rules to write
where mouth and so
the one we'll be using today is pegged
with a surpassing expression grammar
which is I found one of the most
readable ones so how does that work in
practice because it seems a bit hard now
so that's a grammar rule so that's
grammar rule is made of first the name
of the rule and then you're passing
expression so you're parsing expression
will define the input you want to match
and the output you want to return from
that match and so here for a furniture
type rule I'm matching a range of
characters repeating any number of time
and then I'm using that match result
which will be an array of character to
return is a full string of the furniture
type and so it looks a lot like a
regular expression right yes but what's
really nice with this way of writing
different rules is that it's really easy
to combine them so here for example if I
want to extract my simple character
match it's actually really easy
I'll just define a new rule and use that
new rule in my phone each type hole and
what I think is really good about this
is that it's really easy to reuse some
kind of rules in the other ones and also
it makes your language definition a lot
more readable because here I'm I can
basically read that my furnitures type
would be a set of characters and I don't
have to care about like one kind of
character a lot of not of the or not
that's a different role so it it allows
you to write really complex rules in a
really simple way so another way to
combine different rules is to put them
in sequence so here if I want to define
a price I just need to define first what
a number is and then what the currency
is so number will be an integer and
currency would be euro dollar pound
anything you would want to and from that
sequence of character my parser will try
to match both so if only one of them
match matches it's just gonna fail
and once I have matched both those rules
I'm gonna be able to use both match
results which will be which I call here
a mountain currency and I will be able
to combine both those match results
actually in JavaScript so that's inside
the brackets that's valid JavaScript and
to define a new match result for
comprise which will be a combination of
the two others and a final way you can
combine different schools is to put them
separated by slashes and then you will
be what that will do is that this is
these are different options so if I
define an attribute as a price or a
color what your parser will do here is
gonna try to match price and if that
succeeds I'm gonna return the same match
result as false a price and if that
fails I'm gonna go to the next one and
try to match a color and etc etc and
once you have that way of writing
different rules and to combine them in
different ways like I can actually start
defining my full query armor for my
furniture store and here so I said in my
grammar is that I explained in English
that a furniture will be either will be
a type brackets and any number of
attributes and what I think is really
amazing here is that this is exactly
what I'm reading in the code so that's
valid code I actually wrote the fulcrum
out to make sure it's something that
makes sense and so here if you read the
first line in BO it's a it's defining
what the furniture is and I'm defining
it as a furniture type and then a list
of attributes
and if I want to see what a list of
attributes is I can just go to the last
line and see well a list of attributes
is just one by one opening bracket any
number of attributes and one closing
bracket and so what I think what I love
about this is that I can every rule is
actually quite simple and you can go
from very simple rule to a full query
language in a way that's really testable
really easy to to improve on really easy
to extend
that's good that's really readable and
really simple and once you've done that
once you have your full query language
or your rules defined you just have to
run it through back GS and that's going
to generate the passes that will be that
will you will be able to import in your
code so I'm just running it through my
in the command line or you can just use
it the results of a pack loader if you
want to make it automatic and know that
I've generated my password I'm just
importing it running micros read and I'm
gonna be able to have the exact object I
was looking for so another I'm able to
pass my different queries I can just use
that in my search for earth type chair
hash tag blue and I'm gonna only have a
blue chair so I used to have my keyword
search which would return either chairs
or since our blue as there was a blue
table in the results but not that my
query language provides intent you know
that know that I can say well the color
is applied to chair and color blue is
actually a color I can implement it in
my sorry it's matching actually all my
requirements so I have the intent so
that's precise it's also efficient
because I just have to a few keystrokes
step to get results it's readable
because I have the full search in my
query and it's flexible because I can
have any number of attributes any number
of sorry of furnitures and flexible is
actually up to you when you design your
search language so it's very it's a
balanced fine
so did we do it did we solve the search
program forever well not really because
having a custom query language comes
with one big limitation and that's use
our own boring because know that you
have a language that these are valid or
not
the first experience you can give to
your user is that before they would type
anything and that
always work but know what they can do is
that the first search the type is not
valid and you won't be able to pass it
and they won't get any results and
that's really frustrating for your users
so you need to teach them two things
before they are able to write their own
queries and the first thing is the
grammar what is a valid query and the
first thing is a possible attribute so
you want to tell them well you can set
for cheer for a coach for anything you
want so you need to tell them what kind
of values they can put inside average
queries the first thing you need to do
is add documentation that shrimp or town
you always need documentation and to
give quick access to the documentation
but that not that's not enough because
to make them want to go to the
documentation you need to give them a
few valid searches so that they know
that oh that's very useful I want to
learn more about that and so one way is
that rework for us is to having to have
a health playground which is kind of
like an advanced search with so we're
adding better some inputs and but the
difference is this time you're not using
the inputs to make queries to the
backend you're using inputs to modify
the search bar and to add a valid search
inside yourself strong so let's see how
that would look
yeah so here I select chair and studying
chair to my queries and then blue and
once you have a very search the user
will be able to imply himself to improve
upon it and to start typing his own
search queries because it's teaching by
example and that's really good you want
to give him to show him what it looks
like and to show him oh it's actually
very simple I can do it myself now it's
progressive because you start clicking
around and when you feel ready you can
start modifying your search and then if
you feel like you're even more ready you
can sorry you can write your own search
and hide actually is well playground you
can not use it anymore and it adapts to
your user because if they want to learn
more about it they can just type things
and but if they never want to run about
it because they only come on your
website once well they can just use the
click inputs click the inputs and never
care about the query language
it's really not an advanced search
because you don't need to click the
check box anymore so you can use them
but you can also be really efficient not
using them you don't need to put all
your attributes you can add some of them
in the documentation and also since the
state is synchronized with the search
bar you actually don't need to reach the
state of every select apart so it's
actually still very readable and since I
have a JavaScript parser I act it's
actually really easy to implement
because I already know to extract
information from my query to feel the
Select and the only thing I need to add
is a way to when I click to add value to
my query and reprint it again and that's
kind of easy to implement because my
object is simple so I just need to push
a value inside the object and then to
define a print function and the print
function is actually fairly
straightforward because all the context
is in the object so it's easy to go from
all the context back to a string so here
for example I say furniture will be a
furniture name and the print supreme
value of all the attributes and for
attributes since in the attribute name
it contains a lot of context too I can
say well if it's the color you print it
as an ash tag and Z attribute value so
you have no way to generate this but if
you're writing it but yourself is
actually fairly straightforward so and a
few thing you can add to for onboarding
is error reporting so telling the user
why a search query is not valid syntax
highlight if you want to have the most
important information stand out and
autocomplete which is very useful
actually to showing what values they can
type so a set of colors or chair couch
when they start up in the query so
autocomplete is revision so the benefits
of having a custom query language are
it's efficient it's precise it's
readable and it's flexible the drawback
is that you have teaching your users
become really crucial and you have to
care about that a lot more than with a
simple keyword search so good use cases
for custom query language would be true
that user user use repeatedly so if you
have a true that they spend a lot of
time on being if
and becomes a lot more important also
sharing because it's also it's always
nicer to share a small search that's
readable than for object - in exact and
if you want to have integrations like
api's or integrate with other services
it's always nice for the developers to
be able to type the query copy past it
in the HTTP request and that's just
gonna work
thank you for listening if you have any
question